why are we calling men dumb idiots
I hear so many women in marriage call their man dumb clueless
they don't know how to do things
I don't get it
Men are literally so smart in other ways compared to women
women might be emotionally intelligent
but oftentimes men are logically intelligent
so it's very important to listen to them
not belittle them
especially if you're married or in a relationship
why would you want to belittle your partner
kind of feels like some women are out there on a I hate men campaign
I understand a couple bad apples may have made them hate men
but y'all just chuck those apples aside
there's so many great men in the world